morning John probably doesn't make a
huge amount of sense for me to be
addressing this video to you since you
will see me before I'll see this video
and that unfortunately turns out to be
bad news I'm making the City on Sunday
because as this videos being posted I'm
probably on an airplane headed to
Birmingham going to pawpaws funeral
there may be people thinking themselves
right now why is Hank making a video his
grandfather just died it doesn't have to
make a video his hair looks weird but I
mean it's not like I hate making youtube
videos I wanted to talk a little bit
today anyway because they've got a lot
on my mind Oh Papa was old he was very
old he'd been sick for a very long time
it's very strange though to feel like
after all like a fantastic long life in
which he did a lot of amazing things and
he just he was a you know sort of great
person and a wonderful asset to his
community into his family and we owe him
a lot you know beyond you know creating
our mom which was very important not
only to our existence but also our
happiness but even after that it still
feels like it's not fair by the
traditional definition of fair it's like
the fairest thing that ever happened
right everybody who's ever lived either
has or is going to die it's an equitable
arrangement I feel you know like when
young people died people like teenagers
too hi yeah that's not fair it's not
fair for a 16 year old girl to die of
cancer but when a 92 year old guy dies
yeah that's fair right that guy God's
more than fair Papa had more more life
than the average person by 20 years
still makes me super angry but like what
else is life except for a limited time
span in which we get to do stuff but
then it ends it always ends nobody gets
around it you know everybody dies
everything dies everything that lives
died except actually the notable
exception of that jellyfish that doesn't
die um but if it's between being a
jellyfish and dying I'd prefer to be a
person than a jellyfish even if I get to
be a jellyfish forever what are the
stages of grief which one of my in right
now I looked it up it's number two so
he's done past number one I'm not sure
what stage of grief is um the stage
where you eat lots of potato chips and
watch Qi for hours but I'm definitely
inside of that
why didn't I know about Qi I only
discovered it a few months ago and it is
the best it has everything I had no idea
which is kind of great actually because
that means that there's huge backlog of
them that I can watch all all day long
if I want to do it I li spend a little
bit of time talking about something
besides my grandfather project for
awesome nothing is changing with it but
here here's sort of like where I'm
coming from for the project for awesome
this year ever has always been about
utilizing the power of this community an
online video in general and
nerdfighteria specifically to make great
content for nonprofit organizations and
also use that community to promote and
curate the best video when I say curate
I don't mean promote your video or your
friends videos I mean you go out and you
find the best dang project for awesome
videos that there are and you make sure
that they get in front of the as many
people as possible we have a website at
project for awesome comm where those
videos will be submitted you can go to
that website now it's not fully
functional yet because it won't be until
the project for awesome begins at noon
on December 17th but you can start
planning of course many people have
already started making their project for
awesome videos myself included in
addition to project for us being kind of
clearing house for p4a videos there also
be an opportunity to vote for the
charities that are featured in those
videos and the charities that get the
most votes will be getting a piece of
the money that we're raising for the
prep for awesome which is already over
ten thousand dollars you'll see my
project for awesome video not on Friday
but on Saturday because that's when the
project for awesome is nerdfighters
thanks for being awesome John I'll see
you momentarily
you